Let's go to our next caller from the six one
two area code. Who's calling today from six
one two.
Hi David. This is uh, Charlie calling from
the 602 area code. Hey Charlie, what's up?
Can you hear me? Awesome. I am so glad to
be in touch with you. I love your show. Listen
to it all the time. It's great way to stay
informed and uh, get a good objective opinion,
which I appreciate. My main thing I want to
talk, want to ask you about is with all the
recent drama with Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders going back and forth, do you think
Elizabeth Warren is really very compliant
in all this? Cause I kind of feel like this
is mostly being set up by CNN as opposed to
Elizabeth Warren, like pushing this story.
I feel like it's mostly being pushed by CNN
as an organization, but smear Bernie Sanders.
Listen, there's interpretations as of right
now, I don't know which of these is the most
likely. So let's go through the three camps.
One camp is this is a a concerted effort that
was planted by the Warren campaign given to
CNN. They said to CNN, if you guys publish
this article Monday and bring this up on Tuesday,
Elizabeth Warren will confirm that this is
what Bernie said and you guys are going to
have yourselves a real interesting story.
That's one, right? The coordination between
Warren and CNN. Second possibility is that
this is something CNN genuinely dug up with
their four sources that they claim in their
article on Monday and that they decided for
their benefit because they want to have an
interesting debate because remember this story
broke the day after the debate. CNN said,
let's do this in order to create controversy
and generate attention for the debate. They
presented it to Warren and Warren either truthfully
or untruthfully said. Yeah, Bernie said the
thing, the third possibility is that this
is actually something, a concerted effort
that was given to CNN. It could be by the
DNC, could be by Warren, could be by Biden
in the DNC. Who knows the idea, let's run
interference to stop the Bernie surge. Bernie
of course, taking the lead in that important
Iowa poll over the weekend and that's another
possibility here as well. I don't know which
is most likely at this point. I just don't
know
[inaudible] definitely. I think I definitely
want to stay in the camp of people who still
believe in Elizabeth Warren. I don't think
she's a terrible, I don't think she's a bad
person. I think she is definitely not as good
as Bernie Sanders, but she, I think she is
still a very respectable politician and a
woman and I, uh, I respect her a lot. So that's
just, that's just something that I've been
thinking about. Thanks for answering my question.
That was a really good answer.
Now let me ask you this. If you, if you were
to find out that this was Elizabeth Warren's
idea who said over the weekend we've got to
do something about Bernie, let's go and give
this to CNN. Would that change your opinion
over?
It? Definitely would. It would definitely
lower it some. But also I believe that at
this point in the primary, she's only being
beaten in Iowa by Bernie Sanders. Any politician
in that kind of state where it's like you're
thinking about it and it's like the most important
state to win. If from paths, elections and
all that, and there's one person in your way,
you got to get rid of them. I'd kind of understand
why she would go to that length. But as someone
who supports Bernie Sanders over Elizabeth
Warren, it would definitely make me bump her
down in my list of, uh, choices.
Yeah. I mean, I'm hearing that from a lot
of people and it seems that to T to whatever
extent Warren was involved, this may actually
hurt her. And again, if the goal is just to
support Biden by creating a controversy between
the two progressives, it doesn't matter if
it hurts Warren, because the point might actually
be just to get Biden through to the nomination.
Right? That's exactly the thing is that they
might be trying to pit the two Progress's
against one another in an effort to divide
the progressive vote and then suppress Pete,
Buddha, judge some, try to get more of his
support back to Joe Biden. Biden takes the
nomination. That's kind of what I'm thinking.
It might be.
It very well may. And hopefully, I mean by,
by the time we publish this call, we may even
know more about this. I really appreciate
the call Charlie.
Yeah. Thank you man. All right. To talk to
you. Likewise. Take care. Let's go to a quick
break. If you're holding, don't hang up because
we are going right back to the phones in just
a minute or two.